Hey, welcome to the DDPS TDPs
seminar everyone Before we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics. First, please mute
yourself during the talk unless
you have questions. If you do
have questions, you're welcome
to unmute and ask otherwise,
please use the chat room to post
your questions so that we can
address them in the q&a session
at the end. Second, today's DDPS
seminar is open to external
audiences. So no close by
discussion is allowed. And
finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now, let me introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to
host Soledad Vilar, who is an
Assistant Professor of Applied
Mathematics and Statistics at
Johns Hopkins University. She
did her undergraduate studies at
Univer University, US
university, the Republika Rakhi,
and her PhD in mathematics at UT
Austin. Afterwards, she held
postdoctoral position at UC
Berkeley, and New York
University in 2019. She was
selected as a rising star in
computational and data science
or research is funded by NSF.
We're now Amazon and Siemens
Foundation today. So that we'll
talk about the passive
symmetries of machine learning,
which is a pity will be very
interesting.
So please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk. And now without
further ado, let me pass the
baton to. So that by asking one
random person, as usual, today's
random question is,
what is your superpower?
That
people don't usually have? Can
you pick one? Here with us?
Why well, okay, so,
um, so, um, I think that
something that unusual, I don't
know if it's a superpower, but
something unusual for me is that
I'm from a small country in
South America, which is all the
way. And that's
it. It's interesting, because I
think that you get a different
life experience than other
people just because you come
from like, a very unusual place.
So people get very surprised
about it.
Thank you, so that, you answer
that, wow. The stage is yours.
So, okay, so I'm going to talk
about the passive symmetries of
machine learning. And what I
heard about the audience is that
you're mostly physicists,
working on machine learning,
related stuff with physics. So I
don't really need to give you
the first live about deep
learning and how it has done
amazing things change the state
of the art in several domains.
This is just like an
introductory slide. When I say,
well, people do amazing things
with deep learning, image
classification, playing with
reinforcement learning, and
lately, the there has been this
development and protein folding.
And my claim is that in all
these models, a key insight is
the use of symmetries and, and
also the use of over
parameterization. So first, I'm
going to discuss a little bit
about over parameterization. And
then the main part of my talk is
going to be about symmetries.
And you know, in, in deep
learning, we have these models
that we use to fit the data, and
they're very well parameterize.
So we have maybe more parameters
than data points, significantly
more parameters than data
points. So we have a training
set, which are like, say, images
on their labels. And then we
have a hypothesis class, which
is what functions we use to fit
the data. So for instance, a
convolutional neural network
with 42 layers or something like
that. So we train the model and
we obtain one classifier for my
image classification network,
which is like one choice on the
space of parameters, one choice
on the space of weights. So
there are many functions in this
hypothesis class of possible 42
layer neural networks that can
fit the data and even they can
fit the data perfectly. So how
do you choose the right one?
How do you make sure that your
optimization model or like your
demonstation algorithm finds a
function that satisfies that
that not only fits the data, but
also generalizes. Well, and so
there's a notion that people
described in the machine
learning community, which is
called the inductive bias, which
is like,
like, what is the right
assumptions on your model and
your optimization algorithm, so
that the algorithms are used,
they're typically based on local
optimization converges to a good
solution. Namely, that not only
fits the data well, but also it
generalizes to the that he
hasn't seen before, for
instance, a test set that may
have the same distribution as
the training set or different
one, and so on. There's a lot of
interesting work that had
happened in in the past years
regarding over parameterization.
And how, what happens with using
models that are very well
parameterised. And so I have a
few like, plots or like drawings
from papers in the literature.
So one that I like very much,
and you probably know about it
is called Understanding deep
learning requires rethinking
generalization. And this model,
in this paper, what shows is
that these over parameterize,
machine learning models can feed
data, any data that you want,
they can feed a DL zero training
error, and they can feed things
like, like noise, they can feed
the shuffle images with shuffled
pixels, they can fit images with
the wrong labels, and the fact
that they can fit anything tells
you that well, the fact that
they can do it, why do they
generalize? Well, and there's
the there's some explanations
that had to do with like, how
fast they can they can be
trained, and how well they
generalize. After that. There's,
there's other works, what is the
double descent work and there's
also the benign over fitting
work that people like people
there at Berkeley, that that
basically they show that in over
part in our parameterize Moore's
you may get some something that
they can be explained as they
have better generalization. The
idea is that in the classical
statistical regime, you can feed
your,
you you have a regime where like
you do underfitting regime where
you do overfitting. And then
when the capacity of the model
is like,
the sweet spot, then you get the
bias versus optimal bias versus
variance tradeoff. And that's
the best model that you can get,
like the lowest risk that you
can get for this model. And what
they show is that if you do over
parameterize models, in some
settings, you can go below
beyond this, this low bar, and
then get some performance that
is better than the classical
optimal with video with
parameterize moles. That's what
it means. And that's what they
call the double dissent and the
benign overfitting phenomena.
But
all that to say that over
parameterize models have very
weird
performance on they have very
interesting mathematical
properties. And just the design
of the class of functions and
optimization algorithms that
you're using is key for having a
model that performs well, not
only on the training data, but
also in the general test data or
general problem in general. And
so there's the notion of like
the quality correct or a good
inductive bias. So how do you
design models so that they
actually perform well. And so
there's this recent book by
brown stain Bruna and
collaborators that is called
geometric deep learning. And
basically, they claim that you
can exploit the structure of the
input data and if the input
problem or on the problem, so
that in the design of the models
so that they perform well, like
that would give you a good
inductive bias, for example. So
for instance, convolutional
neural networks are designed to
work well with images and they
have a symmetry property, which
is that they are translation
equivariant would like if you're
seeing a cat and you translate
this cat to the side, then the
the fact that they CNN is
translation aquarium is is a
property that is useful for
image classification. It kind of
encodes the semantics of the of
the actual problem. And then for
instance, recurrent neural
networks. This is blood, some
sort of translation symmetries.
And then graph neural networks
exploit a symmetry that has to
do with symmetries that are
like it doesn't it doesn't
I don't know how you express the
graph as an adjacency matrix,
that's a passive symmetry. And
I'm gonna explain in the next in
the next slide, what are the
passive symmetries. So, in the
physical sciences, you may or
may not agree with me, and this
is something that we can discuss
is that there exist two types of
symmetries, the active
symmetries, which are the
symmetries that come from the
observed regularities of the
physics. So, for instance,
images that have to do with
conservation laws according to
not no other CRM. So, for
instance, the fact that if we
have conservation of energy,
that is equivalent to say that
there's a time translation
symmetry, my dynamical system,
or a conservation of momentum,
which is equivalent to a
translation symmetry, and a
conservation of angular
momentum, which can be
equivalent to a rotation
symmetry. So, those are the
active symmetries, symmetries
that are observed regularities
of the physics, and then have to
do with modifications that we
can do to the world and observe
that something is preserved
after we do this modification.
And there's also the passive
symmetries that are symmetries
that are not symmetries of the
world, by symmetries that come
from the fact that when I
express this physical object, in
mathematical terms, the choice
of expressing this object in
math is not unique, I have to
make a choice. And then if I do
a transformation in my choice,
then the word doesn't change. So
this transformation should be
translated in to the physics
into the observer, like into
observations as well. So for
instance, if I express this
object with some set of
coordinates, and then I later
come back and I express the same
object with a different
coordinate coordinate system,
then the then the observables
should be consistent with the
change of coordinates that I
express. And this includes, like
units equivalents, as well,
gauging variances and
covariances, etc. So these are
symmetries that are just like
they come from the fact that
there's not a unique
representation. So they chose
that the representation induces
some symmetries that will show
up. And for instance, say I have
a physical system, and I make
some predictions based on
everything expressed in every
mass expressing in kilograms, if
I change it to pounds, then the,
the data will change. And the
predictions will change in a
predictable way. That's what it
means. Like that's an example of
a classic passive symmetry. And
so the claim is that the machine
learning and data science
methods should be consistent
with the symmetries in order to
be correct.
So you, you want to parameterize
the space of functions, so that
they satisfy the symmetries of
the petroleum, they add things
seem at this underpass of
symmetries. And so an example
that is very, is very common in
machine learning right now, and
people in this is a very active
area of research is the graph,
neural networks or graph
learning.
And the passive symmetry, it's a
very simple symmetry. The idea
is that whatever learning
function that I express in a
graph, so I have my graph, and
then I expressed this graph as
an adjacency matrix. And so this
is one possible adjacency
matrix, the representation of
the graph is an adjacency matrix
is not unique. So I could choose
a different ordering of the of
the nodes in my adjacency
matrix, and it represents
exactly the same graph. So if I
take this, this graph
representing this way, and I do
permutations of these rows and
these columns, then I obtain
this graph, this this
representation, and it's just a
different way to represent the
same object. So the function
that I learned should be
consistent with respect to that
change. So if it's like say, if
I'm just learning a number, say
the length of the shortest path,
then that number should be
invariant with respect to this
permutation. So what I'm saying
is that
f of pi a PI transpose should be
equal to F of A as anybody and
function for all pi
permutations. So this is the
action of the permutation on the
input space, and then the
function needs to be invariant
with respect to that action. Or
if I'm learning like a node
embedding. So I'm learning some
property for each node, then
that node embeddings should be
equivalent with respect to these
permutation action, meaning that
if I permute, the rows and the
columns of my matrix, then then
bang needs to be permuted as
well. And this is an equivalence
so the same group acts on the
input and in the output. They
don't necessarily act on the
same way, but it's just like
that it acts
as so the question is, how can
we efficiently parameterize this
space we might even find
equilibrium functions
With respect to permutations,
and this is what people do in,
in graph neural networks on
graph learning. And so there are
many interesting research
questions in graph learning that
have to do with like how to
parameterize the functions that
on graphs are equivalent. So the
typical way of doing this is by
implementing in the form of
message passing. So because if
you if you write, like message
passing is just like you learn a
function, which is a message
function that each node send to
their neighbors, and that
there's another function, which
is the aggregation function,
that each node like aggregates a
message from their neighbors,
and that is a very simple way to
express something that does not
depend on the representation of
the graph is a matrix. So it's
the equivalent just like
definition, it's just like, you
need to know who your neighbors
are. And that's it. So these
folks, this is like the
classical way of doing good
accurate networks. And, and but
then there's like a very
interesting area of research
that says like, actually, if you
just implement these, these
message passing networks, there
are many functions that cannot
be expressed by them, even
though they're equivariant with
respect to permutations are
invariant. And the reason is,
because like this, this action
by the permutations is connected
with the graph isomorphism
problem, and graphism have some
problem is not an easy problem.
So you may like just just the
complexity of this class of
functions is not sufficient to
separate non isomorphic graphs.
So 39 isomorphic graphs. So
there's like a lot of work,
trying to understand what
functions one can express with
these models, or how you can
modify these monads so that they
can express more functions. And
then some functions like for
instance, classical message
passing neural networks are not
able to compute trivial, trivial
functions, like the number of
triangles in a graph. And so
like, you have to think a little
bit more. And there's like many
interesting words in this space.
Yeah. And so and other questions
that people have studied, are
the stability of the graph
neural networks, how do you
track and how can you evaluate
the transferability? So say,
What happens if I train a graph
in your network on a graph, they
have 100 nodes and then evaluate
them and graphs that have 1000
nodes? How can we say that what
this graphing network is doing
is consistent. And then there's
a lot of work on like the
evaluation of the performance of
graph networks, in benchmarks,
which are being developed and
also in in theoretical models,
like random graph models. But
that's that, so that's kind of
like a connection between like,
some passive symmetry and or
some symmetry, and then a model
that relies on the symmetry,
which is graphing networks and a
lot of mathematic interesting
mathematical problems come from
the actual symmetry of these
models. And there's, that's just
graphing networks. And this is a
an big part of my research, but
I'm not going to focus on it on
on the stock. i We can talk
about it offline, if you want.
Or, or maybe if you have any
questions. I'm happy to answer
them that now. But I'm just
gonna, so the idea for my talk
today was to describe other
symmetries that have to do with
scientific machine learning.
Any question? Okay, so, so why
in machine learning has to do
with
the understanding of the
symmetries that go into the
machine learning models, and the
applications include, like,
dynamical systems, fluid
dynamics, graphs, I just
mentioned that particle systems,
in particular, for instance,
protein folding Alpha fold, uses
equivariant transformers in part
of the architecture. So it
really shows up in many
scientific applications. And
just, it's not just graphs, it
goes beyond that. So I'm going
to explain other ways that
symmetries go into the
definition of machine learning
models and how to implement them
and on how to evaluate them. So
the
so if I have time, I'm going to
describe how to implement
different equilibrium models and
political systems, how to
implement it with violence on
images. And I have a few
applications. One is a toy
example that is easy to see
what's going on. And then we
have applications to cosmology
and to vegetation dynamics that
I can describe
Ah,
yeah. So can I ask the question?
Yes. So earlier you had
mentioned that this this
difference between these active
and passive symmetries.
An interesting example for a
physical system would be where
if I'm thinking about an active
symmetry, how can I get
conservation of energy by
implementing the right set of
symmetries in my modeling or
wherever? So that energy is
conserved? Is that also part of
the consideration here? Yes. So
I'm gonna I have an example on
the at the end of my talk where
we do that. But the idea is that
if you if you know that your
system is coming, Tania, then
you can, you can use something
like a neurology that does
Hamiltonian integration. So then
they like the fact that there's
a, there's a constant
Hamiltonian is already embedded
in the model. So the energy
conservation is part of the
definition of your of your
model. Okay. Okay. Thanks. Yeah,
I look forward to that example.
So, okay, so how do we implement
symmetries? Okay, the classical
thing that people do is to data
mentation. But I'm going to
focus on like architectural
design, which is like, I'm going
to restrict the learning to the
class of functions that satisfy
the symmetries. And the way
people do it is by using weight
sharing, like for instance,
message passing is a form of
weight sharing. Because it's the
same message that goes to to
every node, the message
function, not the same message,
but the same function, then
there is an approach based on a
producer representations that
I'm going to describe very
briefly. And then I'm going to
go into the idea of using the
invariant theory for that. So so
the idea is, so we have a group
action, and maybe I should have
like a little drawing, like
here. So say, maybe either
before or not, yeah, here, I
think I skipped the slide. So
the idea is that you have a
group that acts on a data set.
And then if you, if you apply
the group action to the input,
and then the output doesn't
change, then you say that is
invariant. So for instance, in
this image classification, if
you rotate the image, then the
classifier doesn't change, or
equivariant. So for instance,
here I have this particle
system, and I have I want to
predict the dynamics. So if I
rotate this particle system,
then the predictions will
rotate. And they do have
equivariant ML is that the
hypothesis class satisfy that
for every choice of parameters.
So for every data for every
function, you in your hypothesis
class, it satisfies this
symmetry, so for every day that
f of g times x is equal to g
times f of x, for instance,
here.
So that's the idea. So the
question is, how do you
implement that as a function
that satisfies this property? So
one way of doing that is by
saying, Okay, I'm gonna start
with a feed forward neural
network, which is the
composition of linear functions
or nonlinear activation
functions. And then I'm going to
restrict the linear functions,
so so that they satisfy the
symmetries. And so they're,
since they're not done many
linear functions that are
symmetric, like say, if you say,
like, rotation invariant
functions, how many linear
functions are rotation
invariant? Not very many. So so
then what you do in order to
make the space of functions
expressive, is you extend these
two tensors. So you say, okay,
the linear functions are not
just going to take a vector, but
they are going to take a tensor
of the input with itself k
times, and they're going to
output the tensor with a weight
of the input with itself, k
prime times. And so you want to
look at the functions that are
linear, under equivariant, here
by just extending the action to
each of the orders of the
tensor. And the question is, how
do you do that? And one person
that that did a lot of this work
is test net, which I think was
working for you at some point
recently. So, she, she developed
many of these methods. And, and
the thing that she does is, she
uses representation theory. So
the idea is that how do you
parameterize these linear
functions that are equivariant
in this tensor spaces, and
basically they do this idea
based on group representations,
which basically says that if you
have an equi via map, and
then that is linear, then you
can use some properties from
like, representation to you
theory that says that if you
take take your space and
decompose the space in the in
the reducible components, then
this tensor space, you decompose
it in the irreducible components
with respect to a group action,
then a map is equivalent, even a
leaf in maps, it will also
component of the same type to
itself by a multiple of data
entity. So, the idea is they
take the space
the space that's tensor space,
they they compose the the input
and the output in the reusable
components. So they have these
rules or representations. And
then from these reusable
representations, they just read
off, what are the possible
parameterizations that send one
space into the next. And that's
a paper by Thomas and Smith,
collaborators in 2018. They have
a very nice implementation, I
think in TensorFlow.
But, but the hard part of this
approach is that in order to do
this composition of this tensor
product into irreducible
representations, you need to be
able to compute the claps Corbyn
coefficients, which is, is known
in some cases, but it's hard to
do in general. So, so yeah, so
yeah, so to summarize, the idea
is to take a feed forward neural
network, and you replace the
layers, the linear layers by
linear equation layers on
dinosaurs, and then you use
irreducible representations to
parameterize, the linear goodbye
of layers on these tensor
spaces. That's the idea. There's
another question of like, how do
you choose the not the
activation functions, and that
depends very depends on the
group that you're using, in some
cases is easy, but in some
cases, it's hard to to find
nonlinear activation functions
that work.
So that's, that's a reducible
representation approach.
My, my focus is different is a
different approach to the same
problem, which is the invariant
theory approach. And I think
it's simpler, but it works in
some for some simple league
groups, that people using
classical physics, but in
general is not known what the
invariants are. So it may be
harder to do in general.
Whereas the rules of
representation approach works in
general. So it is the following.
So we have this, this particle
system over here. And the goal
is to start just for simplicity.
So we have N particles in rd.
And our goal is to find all the
barium functions that take these
n particles in rd and output a
scalar.
So we could look at the OD which
is Altana group, or rotation
rotations, which are like all
these they rotations and
reflections. And then there's
the Lorentz group, which is,
is a similar group, but it has a
different inner product. And it
comes from special relativity.
And the idea is that the
function that we want to
parameterize satisfies that if I
rotate all my inputs, the
function doesn't change, because
it's an invariant function. So
in order to do that, we can go
back to the classical work in
group theory by trial, that
shows that the first fundamental
theorem for immodium theory says
that a function is all the
embodiment if and only if you
can write it as a function of
the pairwise inner products of
your inputs.
This is kind of intuitive,
right? So I have a point out, so
I take the pairwise inner
products of my inputs. And then
I write the function on that. So
if I rotate the point, well, the
pairwise inner pros of the
inputs don't change. So the
function that I write is going
to be embedded with respect to
rotations? Or the the question
that we need to ask is like, is
that all? Does that Is that
sufficient to write all the
functions that are embedded with
respect to rotations? And the
answer is yes, and there's many
ways to see it. But but that's
basically the idea. So that
gives you a very simple way to
parameterize just the
environment function. So for
instance, if I want to learn the
energy of the particle system,
then I can write it as a
function that I learned on the
pairwise inner products of the
positions on velocities of my of
my of my point cloud and that
will be invariant with respect
to rotations.
So if I want to write not just
like just a scalar function, but
I want to write for instance,
predict the day
dynamics of this point cloud,
what I can do is I can
parameterize the learning as a
as an equilibrium function. So
say for instance, for each
particle, or for the center of
mass, what I need to learn is a
function that takes these n
vectors in rd. So the point
cloud and output vector in rd
that is equally valuable respect
to rotation. So if I rotate the
input the output rotate. And is,
it's not too hard to see that
actually, a function is all the
equivalent if and only if you
can write it as a linear
combination of your input
vectors times
a scalar invariant function. So
a function of the inner products
as in the previous case. And so
this suggests, or more than for
the learning, basically, the
model is you take your input
point cloud, you compute the
scalars. And then you learn
different functions
at once events, so like this,
this coefficient functions, and
then your output is going to be
a linear combination. And you
can implement this in many ways
you can implement it with
attention mechanisms, for
instance.
And this is part of something
that is can be seen in like a
more general theory that allows
you to translate knowledge from
invariance to equivalence. And
the idea is basically that the
equilibrium functions are the
functions that satisfy like that
this commutative diagram over
here. So say, I have a vector in
V. And then if I apply the group
action, here, let's see if we
will see, yeah, I apply the
group action, then. And then I
applied the function is the same
as applying the function and
then applying the group action
in the output. So you can see
this commutative diagram.
And
then just knowing that you have
a group action in the in the
space V. group action displays W
induces an action on the space
of maps from me to w, so that
the equivalent functions are the
fixed points. And so that
suggests that the knowledge on
the invariant maps is sufficient
to transport that into knowledge
on equilibrium maps. So all that
I'm saying, and I'm not going to
go into the details of this is
that this construction that I
showed you earlier, on how to go
from, like the body and the the
understanding of what the body
and functions are, to what the
equilibrium functions are, is
something that you can do in
general, for other for other
groups, as well,
as well. Now, I'm gonna tell you
a little bit about this example,
which is like a simple toy
example. But I think that it
explains how this mole is can be
implemented. And maybe other
more interesting, we can discuss
more interesting problems where
these Can, can be used. So in
this example, I have like these
double pendulum connected with
springs. And so the problem is
to predict the dynamics at this
level pendulum. And so this,
this model, this, this, this
problem has like a, like an ode
to equilibrium. So say, if I do
a rotation in the xy plane, then
the dynamics of the pendulum
rotates in the xy plane. But
this model is not all three
equilibrium, or at least not in
a priori, because if I do a
rotation that moves the Z axis,
then the model doesn't really
doesn't really behave in the
same way because of the because
of how the gravity affects the
dynamics. But if you're if you
move the gravity vector with the
masses, everything at the same
time, then that is oh three,
which is that this is kind of
like a coordinate
transformation. So we can say
that if you add the gravity
vector as an input to your
learning problem, then this is
an all three whereby on passive
symmetry that you you can
implement. So you gotta learn
the position and momentum of
your of your particles as an all
three will function, assuming
that the gravity is an input to
your model, and maybe the
gravity is fixed, which is
typically in life, but but
still, you you need to be able
to compute the variance with the
gravity as well. So in this
model, this is a Hamiltonian
system. So this is this
Last time translation symmetry
were like they, they come into
union kinetic energy plus
potential energy is conserved.
So if you're going to learn, if
you're going to use
a machine learning model to
learn this, you could say you
can implement the rotation
symmetry this all three. And
also you can implement the
Hamiltonian symmetric as well
like the, the, and then for
that, we have two approaches. So
the classical neural od
approach, which is basically you
learn a differential equation,
you say, my data satisfies the
differential equation that I'm
going to learn from data. So
this this there is a derivative
of my state with respect to
time. And this is an equilibrium
function of my input with
respect to this, OD, or in this
case, oh three. And, and then we
can learn that and then we can
use our all the integrator to do
the predictions. And you, we can
learn the parameters of the
differential equation using
that. So that's one way to do
it. And this would just learn an
OD. But we can also use the fact
that this Hamiltonian is
conserved. And so in order to do
that, what we do is, we are
going to use a Hamiltonian
neural network. So we know that
the system is coming to an end.
So there's a specific, specific
differential equation that the
data satisfies. So I can just
make my model to learn a
Hamiltonian, h, which is a
scalar function of my inputs,
and then use a Hamiltonian
integrator to do the prediction
of the dynamics. And that
incorporates all the symmetries
that we were discussing. So I
think this is the answer to the
question that I got by Ts just
earlier that
I can't comment much more on
this if you want.
No, that's okay. Then I
understood it. Thank you. Yeah.
So so the fact that you use
scalars gives you the offeree
symmetry. And the fact that you
use a Hamiltonian integrator
gives you the,
the Hamiltonian symmetry. And
then other words, like for
instance, there's words by Kenny
Iraqis that implement for
instance, some symplectic
symmetry in machine learning
models by having specific forms
of integrators and specific ways
to parameterize the dynamics.
So, for this example, this
numerical example just shows you
here this like this is a like
the trajectory of the masses in
phase space, these drawings, and
these table tells you that the
more symmetries you implement,
the better the performance you
obtain. So here we are obtaining
like we are implementing the all
three symmetries with the neural
early on, they all three
symmetries with the Hamiltonian
are the, from here to here you
are, you're adding one more
symmetry, which is the time
translation symmetry, and then
it works better. And if you go
to write this, the groups that
that you are using are the
symmetries that you're enforcing
and weaker, weaker, and this
model doesn't impose any
symmetries. So for fixed
training set size, the more
images you implement, the more
constrained the learning is, you
can show there's math results
that tell you that the
generalization error is going to
be small just because you're
constrained to a class of
functions that is smaller, and
is consistent with the ground
truth solution.
So that is for the symmetries
with respect to rotations are no
but other symmetries that have
to do with units are also useful
and interesting. And, for
instance, in this case, and just
in this example, what you can do
is you can see that you're
predicting this coming Tanya,
which is an energy and has
units, kilograms, meters squares
divided by seconds square. So if
I do a transformation, my
training set, so that everything
that had units of kilograms now
has units or pounds, or
everything that had units of
kilograms now is multiplied by
five, then this,
you know, you can predict how
you that would affect the output
by just doing dimensional
analysis. So that's the scaling
symmetry, you can think of it as
the group of scalings acting on
the input,
give you precise known scaling
in the output, assuming that all
the relevant inputs are in the
model
and
If you do that, then that is
another symmetry that you can
implement into your model. And
one way to do it is by using the
Buckingham pi theorem, that
tells you that
that any function that is units
that we wired can be written as
a function of dimensionless
features. So the idea is you
take your input,
and then you can do some
transformations of your inputs,
so that you can construct
dimensionless features. So for
instance, I can take, like the
M, one divided by m two, that's
dimensionless. And then you can
construct the basis of
dimensionless features. And then
you can learn a function of your
dimensionless features. And, and
that's give you a dimensionless
label. And then you can use a
big scaling to give you the
actual dimensional output. And
that's something that people do
in practice in many, in many
applications just working on
like the dimensionless
formulation of the problem. So
for instance, in PDE, s, people
do that all the time, just like
write it, write it in, in a
dimensionless way, so that the
scaling is correct. So
yeah,
so that's the idea. And you can
see, I mean, I'm not gonna go
into the, into the details of
the math, but you can see that
this symmetry can be seen as a
group like this consistence of
the units can be seen as a
symmetry with respect to a group
action, and the group is a group
of scalings
that have to do with the number
of units that you have in the
model in the models. So here, it
would be like, if you ever, like
things can have units of
kilograms, meters seconds, so
the action is by
our oops,
small will be an action by like,
our greater than zero to the
three, like you can scale the
masses, you can scale the
distances and you can scale the
time.
That's, and then if you scale
that, then it affects the output
by scaling the masses linearly
scaling the distances
quadratically, and scaling the
times we like many to one half
negative two.
Anyway, so finally,
I'm going to discuss how can we
mathematically explain how much
do you gain by enforcing
symmetries. And so,
the idea is the following. So if
we have
if we have a learning problem,
and
and you have like a task of
regression task,
then you can define the risk of
like the expected value of the
of the error with respect to the
ground truth.
And, and so, the generalization
gap is going to be the risk of
your function. And so the
generalization gap between like
a function f and the projection
of F onto this basically by the
functions is going to be the
risk of f minus the risk of the
projection of f. And you got to
see that under some assumptions,
they say the group is compact,
and they on the measure that
suppose the data is symmetric,
then you can actually quantify
that the risk, the difference in
the risk is always non non
negative. And it's like just the
norm of the projection of F onto
the space of who might have
functions. So that shows that
you always gain something by
imposing symmetries in some way.
Because, like, the error that
you that you have is decreases
by,
by something that is how much
you throw out when you project
into the space of the mind
functions. Of course, this has a
very strict hypothesis or like
assumptions. And it requires
that, that you can like
understand, like imposing the
symmetries is kind of like doing
a regression and then projecting
onto the space of environment
functions. Whereas in practice,
people don't do that people just
like do a regression into a
space of combining functions. So
it doesn't really match a
projection. But the this is just
one way of explaining it.
So
We have some applications to
cosmology.
Basically, the idea is that,
well, David Hogg is my
collaborator, he is an
astrophysicist. And Kate is his
students. And they work in
cosmology. And basically what
they have is like a very
expensive hydrodynamic
simulation. And then they have a
cheaper darkmatter only
simulation. And so they want to
use the cheaper simulation to
make predictions of why happens
in the in the more expensive
simulations. And so what they do
is they write a machine learning
model to predict the properties
of the galaxies in the more
expensive simulations, by
defining the machine learning
model to be respecting this,
this symmetry. So they
respecting units a group is and
respecting rotational
equivalences, as well.
And they do that by representing
the data in a way that has to do
with the scalars that we just
described before. And they, they
show that machine learning
models that imposes symmetries,
we're better than the ones that
do not impose these symmetries.
That's the idea. And they, they
write it in a way so that the
most that they obtain are
interpretable. So another
application of this is the to
vegetation dynamics.
I'm not going to go into the
details of this application
until unless you ask me but
basically, the idea is that if
you have a simulation of the
vegetation dynamics, the things
that go into these simulations
have a lot of units, because
include, like the rainfall and
water update, and the vegetation
laws, etc, all of them have
units. And so if you're, if you
do it, you if you do a
regression, that is units in
Cuba, then you can see that it
will perform better.
And,
um,
let me just like show you a
little drawing of like how you
can extend these two images. And
the idea is that when you work
on images, you have to use these
ideas of scalars, or vectors and
tensors. In, in an image
setting. So you can use like,
you can extend the things that I
that I told you about using the
scalar formulation for
implementing the query and
functions to an image setting
where like, what you can do
convolutions and you combine
this convolution idea with this
scalars idea. And you can define
more or less that satisfy this
similar properties and produce
nice pictures. So as a summary,
and I like maybe five minutes
over, say that
the enforcing exact symmetries
in machine learning give you the
correct more or less good noise
assumptions, better sample
complexity, it's more
generalization error. And we can
show how to parameterize certain
classes of functions that
satisfy the symmetries of
classical physics, using
basically Einstein summation
notation. And,
and we can extend this to images
that say, Thank you for your,
your time. Thank you. Thank you
so much for your wonderful and
informal, informative
presentation. Very nice. Very
nice. We're going to have a
question and answer sessions, we
have a 10 minutes.
Maybe I can start with a one
philosophical questions. So you
start with a
neural net model, which is over
parameterised. So you have a lot
more parameters to tweak to
represent something, right.
So in some sense, you have a
overdetermined system with a
and you'd like to close the
system by introducing some sort
of symmetric constraints into
your equations, right. So that
you can generalize better. What
if well, that works when, you
know,
some system you're dealing with
has already, you know, some sort
of symmetry has to be there, and
you can impose that, right? But
what if you don't know the
system you're dealing with? You
don't? You don't know ahead of
time, what kind of symmetry you
have to impose.
Is there a way you can discover
that somewhere
Three? Yes, that's a great
question. There's a few papers,
recent papers that try to learn
this image from data. And they
they do it at different levels
of success. But I think that
it's yeah, it's an interesting
question. It's, it's not fully
salt, like people try to
parameterize the symmetries in
one or another way, and then
learn that from data and then
use that for for predictions.
Okay, so there are walks out
there, I can, I can point out
some references. There's
reference, like there's some
work by the group of
Andrew Wilson at NYU, where they
do some learning of the
symmetries on the fly with that.
So basically, they they
parameterize the symmetries like
using that, like simple things
like say, Well, my, my symmetry
needs to be implemented as a
matrix, which should be local.
And then they do like they
basically parameterize things in
terms of the exponential map,
and then they optimize jointly
for the most amount of
symmetries and the smallest loss
for the training error. And then
they just tried to do that that
way. As as one example. So what
if I brought you in San Diego,
where they do something similar
as well? Rosa, you said,
okay, so I know her. Okay,
great.
So let's go to the audiences. I
see. Pat,
posted some questions in the
chat room? Have you wanna unmute
yourself and ask a question
directly? Sure.
Thank you. Yeah, yeah. Thank you
for your talk. So yeah, so you
focused on on Earth.
Of course, the notion of
inductive bias is much more
broader than that. And I'm, and
it's clear that symmetries can
play a role to me than in with
many other different
representations of learned
knowledge. So
I just want like to understand
how much of your analysis is
limited to neural nets, and how
much of it is more general.
So the this is more general, in
the sense that you don't need to
use neural nets, you can use any
form of regression and impose
the symmetries in in that
regression. So for instance, the
people that are doing the work
in cosmology are not using
neural networks. They're just
using simple models, and they're
using their features so that
they satisfy the, the symmetries
of the problem. Yeah. So that's
good. Great, thank you.
So the simple model as such as
what
they are doing
some form of like a lasso, like
a linear regression with with
spicy parts, right. Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
That's it. I had another
question about scale invariance.
Okay. Yeah. Feels feels very
different from me, but what they
talk about his invariants. And
so I'm curious as to whether
there's any weather that comes
up here, like scaling empires?
Well, I mean, there's there's a
branch, there are branches of
science that are who are very,
very focused on systems that
exhibit the same phenomena at
any scale. And, and and I want
to understand whether that's a
different use of the term
invariance, or whether it is
similar, and there's a way to to
model it. And the framework
you've proposed so far is this
was self similarity of these
properties. Yes. self similarity
could be phrased in in this in
this language. Actually, there's
a book by Peter over where they
look at the
self similarity in differential
equations and how we can look at
it in terms of groups in
variances as well.
Okay, thank you. Oh, and Jung
Soo, I just wanted to mention
that rose, you is giving a talk.
Right? Like, like in three
minutes at ISI
and also the link here. Yeah.
You have to register and
probably I'll say, I will send a
link but you have to register.
Or you might invited to this to
this seminar. Thank you. All
right. I'll try and get the link
and put it in the chat box.
Yeah, that'd be awesome. Okay,
thank you.
Awesome. Any other question? I
don't see any other questions in
chat, but
Um, you can ask
by unmute yourself. And then
yeah.
I guess I can ask a question
really quick.
So part of the coming up with
the invariance is is sort of
doing this projection to a set
of parameters, which are like,
in a sense, the minimum set that
you need to describe the system
that takes into account all of
the symmetries and invariances.
Right? So like, in the double
pendulum example, you have the
two invariants. Is there any
sort of intuition behind what
sort of projection you choose to
use as opposed to something like
an SVD? Or?
So what we do is, once the we
know, what is the what is the
symmetry, then what we can do is
we can write this base of
invariant functions with respect
to that symmetry. So for
instance, why did they so to
imbiah functions.
And so sometimes there's like,
very, like, you can write as the
main functions or functions of
these, like small features that
you can construct simply from
the data. So in the case of,
say, all three, then if you
write any function in terms of
the scalars of the inner
products of your inputs, then
that function is going to be
invariant, and vice versa. So
that gives you like, I think
that's where your question was
going. Right? Like, yeah, so
what if it's a more complicated
set of like, like a conservation
law? Something like conservation
of energy? Yeah. So if it's a
conservation of energy, you're
you're probably have, you
probably have a Hamiltonian
right? That you that you're
concerned that you have
conserved? Yeah. So what you can
do is you can write, and also
you know, that it will satisfy a
specific differential equation.
So you can, you can use the form
of the differential equation
that it will satisfy, and then
learn the parameters that define
that differential equation. And
then do you just integrate that
differential equation?
So it's basically you have a
parameterization of the
functions that satisfy that
property, either via the fact
that they're,
like the scalars are constant?
Or be the fact that there's a
specific differential equation
that the data should satisfy?
Maybe you don't know what the
parameters are. But if you know
that, if you satisfied that
specific differential equation,
then you know that the energy is
going to be conserved. Okay. All
right, thanks.
Just really quickly, so a lot of
us are interested in embedding
neural networks inside existing
scientific simulations, in which
case, we're interested in the
networks, not only like
representing the physical
quantities need to be conserved,
but also numerical properties
that won't lead to exponential
blow up and stuff like that. Do
you have any ideas on what kind
of symmetries we could employ to
represent that?
Um, so yeah, this does a tricky
question. So for instance, in
the case of this, they have the
scaling invariance, your urine
balance look like quotients of
things, and that numerically
blows up. So if you want to do
like, if you want, if you have
that symmetry that has to do
with scalings. In fact, you can
have like, very small scalings,
like you can work at different
scales. And that's something
that is numerically unstable. So
you have to be careful with
that.
So you would I mean, that that
is more of
like, how do you do it in
practice, so that it doesn't
really blow up, you have to be
careful. So what we did was, we
constructed by and features, and
we allow the million features to
be within a range. And if the if
there wasn't within a range of
them, we removed them, since
they bind features can be chosen
so that they are
then you can have more than that
than redundant, you can have a
redundant set of invariant
features, you can remove some
invariant features that are ill
conditioned and get only use the
ones that are well conditioned.
And that's sufficient to express
the moment. So incorporating
redundancies and over
parameterization is is better
than doing something that that
may not have that property. So
you can you can remove that ill
conditioned behavior by
incorporating redundant
features. Does that answer your
question? I think so. I'm more
just I get nervous anytime that
I embedded ote and something if
I can't guarantee that it's on
one half of the complex graph.
Yeah, and I wouldn't well they
have
have a comment about it. Unless
it's like something specific
that I have done before. You
know, I think that it could many
problems like that may arise and
I maybe haven't thought about
them.
Sounds good.
Any other question?
This past two after 11.
Maybe it's a time to wrap up.
Okay. Okay. Let's, let's thank
our speaker today for a
wonderful talk and wonderful q&a
session. I'm sure there are more
questions. But I'm sure you
know, all that he's going to be
happy to get any questions
through email, right?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, of course.
Yes. Yeah. All right. Yeah. So
thank you so much for Yeah, for
inviting me. And I hope that was
useful to you. Yeah. And I hope
that, you know, after this event
is initiating some more
collaboration between Lawrence
Livermore and your group at
Johns Hopkins. So let's hope for
that. Thank you. Thank thanks.